mastering the basics of angular's HTTP
module well open up the door to interact
with thousands of exciting web-based
api's by the end of this lesson you'll
have the basic tools you would need to
do things like request weather data
stock quotes nutrition facts as well as
interact with major platforms like
Facebook Twitter and Amazon Web Services
the one thing these products all have in
common is that they provide a restful
api that you can consume from your
angular app Before we jump into the code
let's quickly look at what a restful api
is and how communication works between
the client and the server so here we
have a client on the left and a server
on the right rest is simply a way for
these two parties to communicate in a
standardized way when the client makes a
request it's going to use a specific
verb or method to interact with the
server first we'll go ahead and make a
get request this tells the server that
we only want to retrieve data and we're
not going to modify it in any way the
server will respond with the status code
as well as the data that was requested
if it was a successful request it should
be a 200 level response but if the
request wasn't valid it should be a 400
or 500 level error response a 400
response generally means the client
screwed something up and a 500 level
response generally means there was an
error on the server itself if we send a
post request we're telling the server
that we intend to create new data when
you send a post request you also send
that data payload with it which is the
data you intend to save on the server
after the server successfully saves it
it should respond with a 201 success
message this time saying that the
resource was created in addition to
getting post you also have other verbs
such as put patch and delete they all
work in a similar way just conveying a
slightly different message for what you
intend to do on the server and that's
basically the gist of how rest works
from a very high level now let's start
retrieving data from a restful endpoint
using angular for this lesson I'm going
to be working from a stack blitz project
this allows me to include a link in the
description where you can run this code
and fork it for yourself the first thing
we're going to do is go into the app
module and import the HTTP client module
from angular common ever since angular
4.3 we've had a client module built into
common so just make sure that's the one
you're actually using from there we can
go into the
the app component and import the HTTP
client which works just like an angular
service its injectable so we can just
add it right in the constructor then I'm
going to define a root URL variable that
represents the main HTTP endpoint that
we're going to be using for this demo
I'm using JSON placeholder which is just
a mock API that we can send request to
and receive responses from so we'll just
go ahead and copy and paste the URL and
then we'll do the rest of the work in
angular so first I'm going to opt out of
typescript static typing and we're going
to make a get request to the API first I
define a get post method and then I'll
define the post variable by a coin HTTP
GET and that's going to return an
observable so we'll pass in the route
URL and that should return in observable
of the response from the API and the
HTML the first thing I'll do is set up a
button that will trigger the API call
and then from there I'm going to use
ng-if to loop over the observable and
unwrap it with the async pipe then I
print it as a JSON object but you could
do anything you want here with the
underlying data now if we load the
actual app in stack blitz we should see
the response from JSON placeholder so
after clicking the post button we get a
response of an array of different post
objects for this first example I opted
out of typescript but now I'm going to
show you how to use your own interface
and pass it down to the get method so
we're exporting an interface called post
and it's just going to have a couple of
properties here for an ID user ID title
and body now we can import it back in
the app component and we'll also import
the rxjs observable and then we'll apply
these to the post variable so we're
going to say our post variable is an
observable that contains an array of
post objects that adhere to the post
interface the return value on HTTP GET
is typed as an object so we need to
change that to our post array so if we
go ahead and run this code we get the
exact same result but we have the
benefit of strong typing in our code at
this point so now I'll go ahead and opt
back out of typescript
show you how to send URL parameters with
your requests it's really common to send
a parameter with the request to limit it
or filter it in some kind of way on the
server with JSON placeholder we can
filter posts by the user ID so this is
how we would do it if we were going to
hard-code the parameter we'd have a
question mark followed by the parameter
and equals some value this works fine
but it's not a very maintainable way to
go because if we have multiple
parameters or if they get created
dynamically it's going to be hard to
hard-code them directly in a string what
we can do instead is use angular's HTTP
params class to build these parameters
dynamically we do that by instantiating
a new instance of the class and then we
can call set or append on the parameter
and the value that we want to set and
then we passed that as an object as the
second argument to our get request when
we send this parameter JSON placeholder
will only return the posts that have
this matching user ID we can follow a
very similar process for HTTP headers
which is going to be a very common use
case if you're using authentication in
your app let's imagine that we want to
send a request that can only be
performed by that currently logged in
user in that case we could
hypothetically send a JSON web token
with their authentication details in the
header then the server could decode that
token to validate that this user does
have the right permission to make this
request so just like before we pass the
headers as the second argument in the
get request so now I'm going to test
this out by going to that network tab in
chrome we can inspect the request in the
headers tab and we can see here that it
has the authorization token that we had
defined in angular so now let's go ahead
and send a post request where we
actually modify data on the server so
we'll create a new variable called new
post and also create a new method to
handle this operation post is almost
identical to get the only difference is
we send a body with the request that
represents the data that we want to
modify on the server so we'll go ahead
and create some random post data here
and then we'll send this object as the
second argument to the post request so
we call HTTP post
to the same URL and pass it the data
payload and the HTML will create another
button that triggers that create post
method the new post variable is just a
single object observable so we can get
that data by calling async and JSON then
we can load the app and if we click
create post you see we get back here the
object itself with that new data that
was created on the server one of the
most powerful features about angular's
HTTP client is that you can use any rxjs
operator on it so let's say we want to
map the post down to just the title we
can just throw in the map operator and
then map the post down to just its title
so if we rerun the same method we get
just the title back instead of the full
object as you can imagine there's all
kinds of clever things you can do with
rxjs
to handle multiple requests and map
everything down to the exact data format
that you want you can also use rxjs to
handle errors so in this case we'll
import the catch and retry operators and
also the observable of operator then I'm
going to make the post request on an
endpoint that doesn't actually exist
which is going to trigger an error
response first I'm going to tell rxjs to
retry the request three times if it
fails and if it continues to fail we'll
go ahead and catch it and we'll
console.log it as well as return it back
as an observable I'm doing this just to
show you the response on the front end
and we can do that by returning and
observable of the error itself so if we
try this out we can see we get four post
requests here the original one plus the
three retries and when it fails for good
it console logs the error and displays
the error object in the user facing
front end so that covers the basic HTTP
concepts that you need to know to get
started using third-party API is an
angular but there is one really cool
tool I want to show you before the end
of this video called swagger it's a
framework for building an API is both
server-side and client-side it allows
you to define API code in a readable
Yambol format and it can actually
automatically generate a lot of your
angular client-side code so you would
define the details of your API here on
the left and then it gives you a
readable documented format of it on the
right then if you go up to generate
client and go to typescript angular 2 it
will generate an entire angular app with
the swagger API built into it you can
download the generated code and then
open it in your editor and you'll see
you have a bunch of angular code here
with the HTTP module but I should warn
you this is the previous version of HTTP
and angular so just keep that in mind
many of the methods and concepts will be
identical but you won't be able to use
this code line for line in any case it
should give you some good ideas and help
you jump-start the process of building
your own front-end API client that's it
for angular HTTP if this video helped
you please like and subscribe and if you
want to go beyond the basics consider
becoming a pro subscriber at angular
firebase comm you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as one on one project
consulting thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]